après 6 mois d'attente une nouvelle
fresque sur le thème de l'olympisme a vu
le jour au gymnase nicolasler une
fresque remplie d'espoir réalisée par
l'espace jeune de plaisir mettant en
avant les valeurs du sport et l'idée
c'était de mêler des ateliers dans
l'espace jeune qui venaient de commencer
dans les quartiers avec des œuvres d'art
ça va vraiment être une marque une
marque je dirais qui va marquer non
seulement l'événement des gios mais
également ce que nous pensons nous du
sport et et de la jeunesse de plaisir
une marque ayant réuni artistes et
enfants permettant de tisser des liens
et bien plus encore au début on y
arrivait pas trop mais on s'est entraîné
on s'est entraîné et au bout des heures
on a réussi je trouve que de parler
comme ça à la population par le biais
d'œuvr d'art sur des espaces publics
c'est fondamental des mots d'espoir qui
vont perdurer sur la façade du
[Musique]
gymnase